heather's in knoxville how are you
heather
hi there thanks steve for taking my call
sure how can we help
um well i am a small business owner i'm
actually an artist
who works from home i had
a lot of credit card debt and then
i received a small business loan
and so i was i i saw one of your shows
passed when i accepted it or no i guess
it was earlier
and you and it was like a no no don't do
that
so can you can you explain that
it's it's a 3.75 30-year i do
plan on my my goal is to pay it off
sooner
but can you help me with this i you know
i basically use a loan to pay off the
credit card debt okay
which was very high interest so you you
just moved
your credit card debt to a small
business loan yeah okay
and so your credit card debt was 18 or
whatever
and now you've got like you were like
29. now you got now you got a 4
loan and it was how much money uh
about well it was um uh
well for that loan it was um
about nineteen thousand okay and how
much were your payments if you added up
all your credit card payments back
before you move them
yeah um 400 bucks a month how much are
you paying on the state on the small
business loan
oh i'm sorry i i said that wrong
400 almost 400 was just interest
okay so the actual payments were
um i'm i don't have that number in front
of me probably probably about a thousand
dollars
yeah yeah okay right and how much have
you been paying on the small business
loan
well it i just got it uh weeks ago
so yeah what's your first payment um it
will be a hundred and five
dollars you got it how long ago we'll
start a
week just a couple weeks ago okay all
right it's gonna be 105.5
which will set in one year from now
which i
hope to pay off early and did you say
it's over 30 years or three years
yeah 30 yeah 19 000
okay yes let me point out to you what
the problem is yeah please okay you did
save on the interest rate
yes that's wonderful the problem is you
feel like you did something
well and what ends up happening is now
you're going to pay 105
a month payment instead of paying a
thousand dollars a month
right if you paid a thousand dollars a
month you'd be done in 19 months
but 99 of people don't do that
right because they fall into this
psychological trap
of a debt con consolidation loan that's
basically what this is you got conned
thinking that the lower interest rate
was your problem when in reality your
problem was
not interest your problem was you you
had a nineteen thousand dollar problem
and you tried to solve that by borrowing
your way out of it
so now you're there though i'm not gonna
beat you up for where you are today
but you ask me what the problem with it
is the problem with it is it doesn't get
people out of debt because they don't
change their behaviors
matter of fact they do change them but
they change them negatively
meaning you end up paying less on your
debt instead of more
if the net result of this was people
would pay 1500 a month instead of a
thousand a month
if but they don't as you can well
imagine they pay what is asked and
nothing more
and your lifestyle goes up 800 bucks a
month and
you know all this i got to buy this and
oh i needed to do this and now and i'll
get around to it later i got 30 years
yeah yeah yeah heather so let's talk
about this where you at now
i mean you ha you're here you got 30
years
you're not i don't i probably don't
actually but okay well i was just about
to say that
you're not taking 30 years um no i
honestly want you to go back to paying
what you were paying i want you to put
more snowballs yeah
go back to doing like the 1500 a month 2
000
a month what do you make what's your
household income okay
uh it's well i'm self-employed i'm an
artist i know what do you make
you know uh i make enough just to cover
the rent and i mean i'm sorry the
mortgage
and the bills and feed and all that
and then uh so i guess uh
you know i have to take in at least um
about four four to five grand a month
so um to get to get by forty five
hundred
forty yeah forty five hundred yeah okay
yeah that's fair
so would you agree heather that maybe
you need to pick up something else on
the side
pardon me would you agree that you need
to get some extra income coming in
um well i i honestly uh
i don't i don't know how to do that i
mean i'm
you know 53 yeah not even a high school
education i'm an artist for a living
this is what i do i don't know anything
else can you do more
art uh honestly that's that's me working
a lot
yeah okay well we may need to raise your
prices because the bottom line is is
that you need to pay
19 000 off in one year yeah that's where
that's what you need to aim at and
that's about sixteen hundred bucks a
month
yeah and that means you're going to
tighten your budget and raise your
income
and um but i think you were looking for
me to say that this is all
okay i'm not gonna be mad at you for
doing it but it's not okay
because it gives you permission to stay
in debt
longer rather than get out of debt
faster and that's what the banking
institution
wants from her they want you to be there
they want you to be owned by them the
rest of their life
and i'm estimating dave 19 000 with a
3.75 interest rate over 35 years is what
about 20
28 000 27.
she wasn't planning to do that yeah but
people don't plan
that's what i was about to say yeah so
she wasn't planning to but she probably